Speaker 1: With Donald Trump getting federally
indicted, there have been a number of people
coming out of the woodwork to make the case that
the best thing for the country right now would
be for President Joe Biden to step in and pardon
Donald Trump for the crimes that he's accused of.
The arguments tend to center around this idea
of healing the country or assuring people that
the Department of Justice and law Enforcement in
this country apply the law equally. And they're
not operating in any sort of political fashion.
There have been a number of people in media making
this case, and I came across this one op ed in
the Hill. I wanted to rebut having to do with
this topic. It's called The Nine Reasons Biden
Should Pardon Trump. It's written by Chip Muir.
So I thought it would be good to go through these
arguments one by one, to go through all of Chip's
nine points and see if any of these arguments
are convincing. So reason number one that CHIP
provides is that first, historical precedents in
the aftermath of Watergate suggest that a pardon
would be the best outcome for the nation. On
August 9th, 1974, President Nixon resigned
the presidency in the wake of Watergate. One On
September 8th, President Gerald Ford pardoned him.
The gesture curtailed the acrimony over continued
Watergate fallout and started the process of
moving forward. Though Nixon felt he was innocent
of criminal conduct and should not have to accept
a pardon, the pardon ended his legal jeopardy
and allowed him to acknowledge he should have
handled the situation better. In either case, a
humbling, yet gracious lifeline allowed America
to move forward. Well, just because it happened
once before that one, presidents pardons another.
That doesn't mean that it has to happen again.
And it certainly doesn't mean that it was the
right move. It doesn't mean that it was right for
Ford to do so. And also, you have to remember that
Ford and Nixon were in the same party. Ford was,
of course, Nixon's VP for a time. So there was a
political reason to pardon as well to protect the
interests of the Republican Party at the time.
Now, you can make the case that the pardon did
allow the country to heal from Watergate and move
forward. But I would argue that we would also have
had that healing had Nixon been charged and gone
through the criminal process, whether he was found
guilty or not. Then once it was all said and done,
even though it would have taken a little bit
longer, sure, then we could realize that, okay,
justice has been served in this case. Nixon was
treated just like any other criminal defendant
would be. And the jury came up with their
decision. The judge carried out the sentence
and bam, justice has been served. Now we can move
on as a country from this Watergate scandal that
ultimately still would have happened. It may have
taken a little bit longer, but that would have
been a totally fine course of action in my mind.
Also, we have to remember that Gerald Ford didn't
win a term of his own. He lost to Jimmy Carter
in the 1976 presidential election, suggesting
that maybe the American people wanted to see Nixon
prosecuted instead of getting this pardon. Now we
continue. Second, it is historically unprecedented
for an American president to prosecute his likely
opponents. The US has had six presidential
election rematches, including the John Quincy
Adams Andrew Jackson rematch of an alleged stolen
election. Regardless of personal belief over
legitimacy, the legitimacy of the indictment, the
action itself is unprecedented. Republicans are
sure to and should use this indictment against
Biden to show a weak and continuously weakening
president. Trying to use his power to supplant an
election. A pardon takes away this talking point
as Biden would be using his official pardon power
to avoid handicapping his likely opposition. Well,
I got to say, it's also unprecedented to have
a president like Trump who didn't care one
iota about the rule of law in this country,
who time and time again showed his depravity
and his corruption. Biden also, for his part, is
staying out of this. And he's saying that he's not
going to talk about the case. It's the DOJ, after
all, that is prosecuting him. There's no evidence
that Biden himself has anything to do with the
charging decision. And if Biden does pardon Trump,
then Republicans ultimately are not going to be
gracious and kinds. They're just going to keep
attacking him. They're going to talk about the
other issues like inflation and the culture war
and the border and guns. And they'll continue to
criticize Biden. It's, if anything, going to make
Biden look like a pushover and like he's weak if
he decides to do this. And part of Donald Trump,
we continue. Third, Biden would appear magnanimous
as a candidate. The Biden camp tried to paint him
as looking presidential and restoring norms.
Reality has painted a different picture from
his underwater approval ratings net -14 weakness
among independent voters and video clips that
routinely show confusion. Biden has failed to live
up to the image his campaign wanted to project,
but a pardon would be a shockingly magnanimous
gesture, shoring up any such image problem. Look,
if voters are trying to find the most magnanimous
candidates, they're already going to go with Joe
Biden because they know who Biden is. He's an
empathetic person. He cares about the average
working class person, whereas Trump is seen
as vindictive and this egomaniac type. If
it's a battle about who is the most magnanimous.
Obviously, Joe Biden's going to win that every
day of the week. He doesn't have to pardon Donald
Trump to get a reputation of being magnanimous or
a better person when it comes to personal values.
Fourth, Biden has his own classified documents
problem. He's had documents in his University of
Pennsylvania office and classified documents in
his garage near his Corvette. Offering a pardon
minimizes the accusations of double standards at
play. This is a false equivalence. There is a
world of difference when it comes to the types
of records that both presidents had in their
possession, the amount of documents and how
serious they were, the level of classification
that they had. And more importantly, Joe Biden
cooperated. His lawyers turned over the documents
in questions immediately, no questions asked,
whereas Donald Trump lied to the authorities
repeatedly and refused to hand them back,
even when faced with a subpoena. Fifth, Americans
are rightfully concerned about the overreach of
federal agencies in political matters. Expect
President Trump to vigorously defend himself
with accusations of political motivations at
trial. While it may or may not help at trial,
it will work as a political tactic with the
electorate. By this logic, Barack Obama should
have pardoned Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump
should have pardoned Democrats like Hunter Biden,
who were embroiled in scandal. Just pardoned
anyone that's being investigated as apparently the
point that's being made here. So it doesn't look
like federal agencies are interfering too much in
our politics. What would actually happen if this
was the case was would be that we would create
this sentiment where our elites are completely
above the law. We already have that sentiment here
in this country. You would exacerbate that and
you would make it clear that there is a two tiered
system of justice in this country. One for the
elites who are getting pardons left and right and
one for regular folks who have to go through the
criminal process and may be found convicted and
sent to jail without the possibility of getting
pardoned themselves because they're nobodies after
all. Sixth in the Art of the Deal. Trump discussed
the antitrust suit his USFL brought against the
NFL and specifically mentioned how important it
was that the NFL on a daily basis gave interviews
to win in the court of public opinion. President
Trump will use every day in the run up to trial
and at trial to rail against the corruption of
Biden and his DOJ and FBI by offering a pardon and
not providing Trump with the spotlight of a trial,
President Biden would take away Trump's ability
to demonstrate how unfairly without precedent he
has been treated. By offering a pardon, President
Biden would take away Trump's most significant
campaign opportunity, his trial. I got to tell
you, Trump is going to be able to capture the
media's attention no matter what, no matter if
this trial is taking place or not. He is going to
be able to use all of this stuff to his political
advantage when it comes to his base, at least no
matter what, even if this case is dropped. Because
you got to remember, he's also going to have other
trials to concern himself with, including trials
that are outside the purview of President Joe
Biden, like the one out of New York, for example,
and the one out of Georgia that's likely going to
come in the next few weeks. So even if Biden was
to do this for the sake of not making the trial a
focal point in the election, will Trump could just
talk about the other trials that he's dealing with
and you're not going to accomplish getting this
out of the campaign focus just by pardoning Donald
Trump is the point. Seventh, that the converse of
President Biden looking magnanimous and offering
the pardon is that Trump would potentially look
weak. Innocent men do not need pardons. The pardon
is a lifeline and so on. And it's the same concern
that Nixon expressed during his month of purgatory
after resigning the pardon would make him look
guilty when he wanted public exoneration.
Accepting a pardon would be the logical and
rational decision for Trump. But Democrats
can spin it to say that Trump needed Biden's
generous pardon to avoid a certain conviction
and imprisonment. Now, this one, of course, is
just silly because we know that if Biden pardons
Trump, then Trump would just turn around and make
the argument that, look, the Biden administration
had this flimsy case against me. They knew that I
was going to beat the charges so strongly in court
that they had no choice but to pardon me. And his
supporters will eat that up. They're not going to
think that Trump is somehow weak and presumably
guilty because he accepted a pardon. That's just
not how Trump and his supporters operate. Also,
Chip writes about how innocent men don't
need pardons, while innocent men also aren't
convicted of crimes, at least not typically. Of
course, there are some cases where that happens,
but generally speaking, innocent men aren't
convicted of crimes. So if you want to paint
Trump as a criminal, and that's, I suppose, the
strategy for going forward politically, just let
the process play out because it looks like this is
a rock solid case against him and Trump is likely
going to end up convicted here. Eigth. Trump might
moot the issue by declining the pardon. Trump is a
fighter. He will want to vindicate himself in
both the court of law and the court of public
opinion. He might see a pardon as denying him
that opportunity, making it very difficult for
him to accept the pardon by offering the pardon,
knowing full well that it might not. Accepted by
Trump. Biden puts Trump in the difficult position
of either losing his chance at public vindication
due to the generosity of his opponent, or risking
a trial and conviction after a way out had been
offered. In this sense, offering a pardon is a no
risk proposition for Biden. We're really grasping
at straws at this point. Trump is potentially
going to spend the rest of his life in prison
over these charges. There's a real possibility
of that at the very least. Even if you think it's
unlikely because he's a former president. These
are serious charges and there's going to likely
be some consequences for them. He's terrified
of that. He wouldn't reject the pardon because
he knows that there's a serious possibility of him
ending up in jail. Rejecting the pardon would make
no sense politically because he could just, like
I said, use this to his advantage and say that.
It was he was pardoned because of the flimsy
case against him. He would accept it in a second.
Right. Because that would just be one thing he
doesn't have to worry about. And he wouldn't
think that it would be any sort of liability for
himself in the 2024 election. He would see it
as Democrats admitting to the fact that there
was a witch hunt against him. Ninth and last,
the progressive wing of the Democratic Party has
spent years trying to destroy Trump and they have
been beaten each time. The progressive wing would
be furious if Trump escapes their clutches because
Trump was pardoned. But Biden's polling with
independents is deeply underwater, and these swing
voters are also polling at a net -55 points On the
question of whether the nation is on the right or
the wrong track, offering a pardon, knowing
how deeply unpopular the move would be with
progressives would demonstrate that Biden is not
beholden to that wing of his party. Alternatively,
failing to offer a pardon would be further proof
that he is beholden to the most extreme voices in
the Democratic Party and bog him down even further
with independents. Well, I certainly disagree with
the premise when it comes to this one, because
progressives have had their wins against Donald
Trump over the years from the two impeachments to
defeating him at the ballot box in 2020 to taking
the House in 2018 and the Senate in 2020, and
then fighting off the red wave in 2022. Also,
I'm not sure that progressives are more in favor
of prosecuting Trump than generic Democrats are.
I'd like to see the polling on that one. But the
most important thing from this ninth point here is
that you're maybe ignoring the other side of the
equation. You can say that, okay, It's possible
that Biden will pick up some independence from
pardoning Trump, but he couldn't. He also lose
some of those progressives you're talking
about if he decides to do this, could in
some progressives decide to vote third party or
vote for a challenger to Biden in the primary or
stay home altogether? You have to calculate
that also into your equation. So overall,
those are the nine arguments. I don't think any
of them make sense or are all that convincing.
If you want to show that no person is above the
law, no matter how rich or powerful they may be,
then you have to prosecute when you have
reasonable suspicion that crimes were committed.
Otherwise, you are giving Trump and the people who
come after him the green light to do whatever they
want because they think that they'll get away with
it. And even if they don't entirely get away with
it, then they'll get a pardon and effectively
ultimately get away with it. So I wonder if
Trump was accused of more serious violent crimes,
whether people like Chip Mueller would be making
these exact same points because they all would
apply. Right. And maybe it's taking it to an
absurd level to say that everyone would be calling
for Biden to pardon Trump if Trump had committed
a crime like murder or something like that. But
it shouldn't be even viewed through that lens. It
should just be viewed as their crimes on the
books. And if anyone, no matter who you are,
commits them, is accused of committing them,
you're going to be taken through the criminal
process and treated just like anybody else. All
right. We're going to go to a break now, but
we'll be back with the final segment of the David
Letterman Show after these commercial messages.